derrag vide ou à moitié vide dans ce
magasin de bricolage les clients peine à
se fournir en matériaux de rénovation et
de construction
au rayon des grands absents le bois
d'habitude vous n'avez que des piles qui
sont de cette taille là en terme de
volume voilà à peu près une centaine une
centaine de tablettes par référence et
là on est plutôt sur une moyenne de 20 à
30 tablettes est encore parfois même une
malheureuse tablette qui restent là et
sur certains produits qui sont notamment
des plots esb est un qui est un produit
qui est beaucoup utilisé dans la
construction bois notamment donc avec
des fortes demandes c'est des produits
ou carrément on a eu des références qui
sont ils sont complètement supprimées on
avait jusqu'à trois références
différentes et là on en a plus qu'une et
avec des volumes très très restreint ce
magasin d'une grande enseigne de
bricolage est quasiment livrés tous les
jours mais il ne reçoit plus que 20 % de
ses commandes
donc ça c'est une commande d'un
semi-remorque complet de chez nos
fournisseurs de bois et voilà ce qu'on a
reçu ce matin donc trois quatre cinq six
dix petites palettes sur un semi complet
ce n'était pas l'auteur nos espérances
non n'espérait avec le camion qui
arrivait de pologne mais on n'a pas eu
grand chose malheureusement en raison du
manque de voix les prix flambent ces
planches sont habituellement vendu 9
euros leur prix a été multiplié par deux
avec cette écurie de matériaux le
directeur de cette surface de bricolage
grand public et même contacté par des
professionnels depuis une quinzaine de
jours quinze jours à trois semaines et
se passe pas une journée sans qu'on ait
deux trois quatre appels de
professionnels notamment du bâtiment
autour des métiers de la couverture de
la charpente alors c'est surtout tourné
aussi au niveau de la demande de bois du
bois de charpente pour nous faire des
demandes de tarifs des demandes de
quantité en stock et on le voit on a
beaucoup plus d'entreprises
ils viennent se dépanner chez nous parce
que sans doute que leur filière
habituelle ne peuvent plus le peuple et
les fournir ou peut-être voilà ont des
quotas de jesper comment ça se passe
mais des quotas pour les fournir et
voilà et vient d'acheter du bois de
charpente chez nous notamment d'après ce
responsable d'organisation
professionnelle qui représente près de
1200 entreprises et cent mille salariés
du secteur de la construction cette
pénurie débuté en juillet de l'année
dernière s'explique par des problèmes
d'ordre géopolitique il y avait un
embargo décidé par les états unis qui a
bloqué totalement le marché du bois avec
une polémique qui a couru pendant l'été
sur les exportations notamment de grumes
à ce phénomène de pénurie qui était lié
aussi un contexte international avec une
problématique sur les containers qui a
été aussi très suivie avec aussi cette
problématique tu as du bois des tensions
sur l'acier aussi ça c'est correspond
plus à la partie d'hier est américaine
et au phénomène est lié à l'asie aussi
et puis d'autres phénomènes plus interne
sur la plaque de plâtre sur des produits
d'isolation sur le ciment sur sur
d'autres produits sur lesquels il ya eu
des tensions un peu moindre mais
néanmoins très affirmée quand même si
les approvisionnements s'améliore très
légèrement grâce à des mécanismes
gouvernementaux mis en place ces
derniers mois un retour à la normale
n'est pas envisagé avant mars prochain
[Musique]